- L'ampleur des dégâtse e e e e.
Les pluies torrentielles qui se
sont abattues sur le Kentucky
ont été impitoyables. Les morts
Parmi eux, ces quatre enfants,
âgés de 2 à 8 ans.
Et le bilan pourrait
s'
"Des ceaiaines de personnes
sont toujours portées disparues,
dit le gouverneur de l'Etrtrtrts
pourrait prendre des mois."
De 20 à 27 cm de pluie sont
tombés sur l'est du Kentucky en,
provoquant des inondations
sans précédent dans le secteur.
Plusieurs ont dû quitter
"Nous avons tout perdu",tttttt.
"Tout ce que nous avons,
c'est les vêtements que nous
portions quand nous sommes
Quelques centaines de personnes
sont hébergées dans des refuges.
Les autorités tentent de fournir
à ceux qui en ont besoin.
Des ponts eteses routes sont
endommagés; des communautés
ont perdu l'eau courantelelelel.
"Nous avons besoilance ce rési.
Et pour ajouter au malheur,
on prévoit encore de la pluie
dans les prochaines heures...
ce qui pourrait aggraver
la situation.
c'est le feu qu'on doitcombattr.
Le brasier le plus destructeur
depuis le
fait présentement rage près
de la frontière de l'egegon.
Il a détruit plus de
20 000 hectares de forêt d d d .
Au moins 2000 personnes ont dûs;
des refuges ont été mis sur pied
pour les accueillir.
"Je n'ai plus de maison, plus
dit cette dame.
A Avec les températures qui
grimpent et la sécreresse
qui s'aggrave, la Californie
est plus vulnérable que jamaisf.
Depuis que l'on tient des
statistiques, les années 2020 et
2021 sont les plus dévastatrices
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréa